i cannot believe how long charlie has  lasted after eating that brownie all  right  snow machine chop set what's with the  chopping dude i'm shouting all of my  action  and mostly power he's lost his damn mind  that's loosely based on a guy that i saw  in washington square park and this guy  had like a small crowd of like maybe  five people watching it  and he had a bandana covering one eye  and he had like  a wooden sword and he held the sword and  like he did like a little moving just  for go this was his whole show uh  this is a move  uh  that's a move  uh  uh this is a move  uh chopping cherries is for accuracy  chopping watermelons for power uh this  is a move  uh  and then he was trying to he bought the  petition the petition was trying to get  people to allow him to use a real sword  in the park he was not allowed to use  a sword in my square park